can you say hello to Alex hello me for
months mother of two amy downs has had
to make do with FaceTime for support but
her best friend who lives alone has now
decided to form a support bubble with
Amy's family from my point of view it'll
be really nice to have an extra pair of
hands when my partner is in work when he
does have to go in as a teacher it's
really hard to have to do to look after
two children I'm sure everybody's like
nodding or thinking yeah of course it is
hard but I found it really difficult
the single mom fear is skeptical about
the idea she's been working and caring
for her five-year-old son during
lockdown when it was first announced I
felt excited because I thought great you
know we can finally have some human
contact but when I thought about it more
I started to get confused when you start
finally get to you know inviting people
to bubble with you it's it's almost like
you're asking them to marry you the
months have been restrictions the high
streets of closed roads have been
deserted and people have been allowed
only one bit of exercise a day but
lockdown measures are now being eased
and in some areas the our number which
measures the virus's ability to spread
is now above one clearly lots of people
have been living alone and haven't seen
friends and family for many many months
but Boris Johnson is describing these
new rules as a targeted intervention to
help them most lonely but they won't
apply to those who are still having to
shield themselves
indeed the lockdown has been tough for
everyone but charities have been
offering particular support to single
parents seem to have considered single
parents specifically single parents have
been locked down for what 10 weeks many
of alone they're solely responsible for
their children is it's relentless and
they're full of anxiety as lockdown
measures are eased so many are getting
to finally see loved ones something as
simple as human interaction has never
been so valued Rebecca Williams Sky News